I want to jump to this story from Media
Matters
Luke you want to read that one
it is titled timpoole and co-host to
make absurd claims that the government
wants to control your cooking through
the power grid you don't want to know
why that's really funny
so Luke they uh they're ragging on you
here because you mentioned uh and it was
Jamie Michelle from gays against
groomers
and you said for me this is happening in
order to push the kind of digitized
everything to fully have a technocratic
society you need everyone dependent on
technology and if you're able to cut off
that technology you're able to control
people more and cutting people's ability
to heat their own food by simply
clicking a button that could be easily
done with this new policy and I think
that's what they're really doing in my
opinion
Media Matters as it's absurd except in
California they already turned off
people's ability to you to charge their
cars in Colorado people got notices that
they opted into a program
they couldn't change the heating on
their homes they couldn't turn the air
conditioning up
so when you see is this how this other
media laundering works
you see a thing happen they say you
cannot charge your car because the grid
is overloaded that happened then they
say you cannot turn on your air
conditioning because the grid is
overloaded then we sit here and go now
they want everyone to have only gas
stoves they want to be able to control
the Grid or electric stoves electric
electric stoves and electric cars which
they wanted to put on the grid in
California
or diesel cars and they've already
turned off yeah so we're not speculating
at all we're saying hey you didn't think
they already did if they get this they
can do it more and then Media Matters
comes out and says what a weird
conspiracy theory yeah New York
California Washington and uh Maryland uh
Maryland or Massachusetts I I think one
of those two someone has to correct me
on uh in the chat room there all have
quasi-natural gas bands in place and
programs that phase them out over the
next decade the Biden Administration is
of course working closely with the EPA
to make this a federal policy and
obviously with the grid being overloaded
in many instances this is obviously
going into a a why would they be doing
this other than trying to one control
everyone or to create uh organized chaos
what's the reason here can someone give
me an explanation here did they give us
an explanation here what Media Matters
explaining why this is happening I don't
I bet they didn't I haven't read this
article but uh I'll I'll you know eat my
own words if they did
is what I said if they ban gas stoves
Nationwide that means rural people won't
have access to a lot of those uh what
I've accessed and a lot of those people
have gas tanks their houses which would
put their cooking on the grid and that
grid can be controlled by external
forces granted you can also get solar
the thing about solar is that even when
you're in a rural area because we set
this up you can get your own gas tank
now you can heat your house now you can
cook your food you don't worry about it
with solar you still have to get
permission from the utilities in the
grid to turn on but theoretically you
could create your own solar internalized
Grid or whatever but um I think yeah
this is this is another step towards
absolute control yeah and now you add
that with smart cities smart grids
walkable cities surveillance cameras
artificial intelligence facial
recognition they're setting up
essentially a prison all around you a
technocratic digital one that there's no
escaping and don't forget the voice of
the robots always got to be British I
don't know why but they do and then like
you're gonna go to your kitchen and
you're gonna go to your refrigerator and
there's gonna be camera on it and you're
gonna try and open it it won't open and
it's gonna be like I'm sorry Luke you're
looking pretty fat and you're gonna be
like I'm hungry no you're not and then
it just doesn't open yeah I mean not
seriously like that but I wouldn't be
surprised if it was like warning your
refrigerator has been turned off due to
excessive use usage you you are over
your allotment of carbon by 47 points or
whatever if you open your fridge your
food will spoil yeah carbon social
credit score through the Central Bank
digital currencies that they're all
talking about implementing through the
world economic Forum in Davos so yeah
it's already here yeah many instances I
imagine it's like we're playing a game
of chess and Luke is saying look they
can move their Knight here and that
would be a problem and then Media
Matters says no no that's not a problem
at all and we're like wait a second you
can make that move so that stuff like
that actually wakes people up I I the
more they do silly stuff like that it
wakes people up look at there's even the
quote from Luke saying oh your Tesla is
also going to be off too yeah it's like
Luke's saying if the Knight gets moved
there that could be a problem and they
say Luke said that the government's
planning on moving his night there and
looks like I didn't say that they are I
mean at least in your quote you didn't
say they are you said I think that this
can happen I mean he's everybody playing
this what you think can happen I don't
think what other people yeah when I
express my opinions I say I'm expressing
my opinions because it's important to do
that because again uh we don't know for
sure what the future is gonna going to
look like but we see through the UN 2030
Vision we see through the great reset
through the build back better we see
through all their talking points their
own articles their own websites them
calling for this essentially having
total control of everyone's life through
technology and whether it's your
refrigerator having Wi-Fi or your
blender or your stove or your car being
dependent on the grid having having you
know smart grids having everything
online leads to a lot of possibilities
of a lot of powerful people using that
power and authority over you to punish
you arbitrarily for whatever they want
did you see Klaus Schwab saying uh the
next thing bad thing will be if the
power grid goes out across the earth I
mean it was just a Twitter video I'm
saying like could you imagine a life
2035 where some false flag or some
organization decides to shut off the
power grid of the entire planet and then
people can't cook they can't drive and
then they start getting These Warnings
on their phone we need you to mobilize
to do X like people are going to be out
of their freaking mind they'll do
whatever the government freaking tell
like we do not want to find ourselves in
that position that is my point and it is
like do the math do the math if you
think it can happen and you've done the
math and it shows that can than it can
no matter how many times people ridicule
yeah we're slowly and surely losing our
rights let's and not only that we're
losing our privacy we're losing our
ability to be secure and we're heading
down one particular road and it is it's
a pretty clear Road we're on a train and
there's another train coming and now
claiming that a train's coming or you're
on the train is is somehow absurd so
whatever yeah there's no dispute that
the government could do what Luke is
talking about so it's interesting that
they don't cover that like that could be
a problem whether it's on purpose or not
if you get everybody on electric devices
then you have more control over them
yeah I mean imagine if Hitler had the
technological advancements that that we
have right now I mean he was already
using IBM he was already using some of
the biggest you know corporations in the
world that we're working with him and
helping him facilitate a larger his
larger paragraphs would you ever watch
Justice League bro no I don't I don't
know I can't remember it's been a long
time since I watched this episode but I
think it was Vandal Savage I'm not sure
but the not all of a sudden history
changes in the Nazis had won in the
future and it's because a single a
single like 20 2000's laptop was sent
back to Nazi Germany there's a really
awesome point to make for a kids show
because like to understand the
computational power of a modern laptop
in the hands of a world power it's like
dude the Enigma machine was this like
ultimate device the Nazis had and it was
just like this rudimentary analog device
where they moved cables around to encode
encrypt messages and I I have to imagine
that like Enigma encryption is like dog
crap compared to today's computers and I
bet any modern laptop well I could be
wrong about this but I'd assume a modern
laptop could have could crack the Enigma
encryption so like I watched uh what was
that movie with the with better at
Cumberbatch
I thought it was a really bad movie by
the way but you know basically he builds
this this machine that goes through
every possible you know uh
a passcode or like citation permutation
to figure out what the Nazi messages are
the imitation game yeah there you go and
it's like he builds the computer it's
like one of the first computers it's
mechanical and things are just like
spinning
man you take a modern cell phone for 20
bucks yeah and you're gonna like press a
button it's gonna go like decrypting
yeah look like don't you think they'll
be pretty fast again like just to run
like literally just brute forcing it
with a laptop eventually I think it
would it wouldn't take too long for it
to to do what to crack Enigma I don't
know enough about Enigma I I think
Quantum Computing is insane though
because it can treat numbers as a one
and a zero and it's trying to figure out
number strings okay if if if homie could
build a computer in like 1941 yeah or
whenever it was or 43 to crack an
encryption I'm pretty sure our computers
today can easily correct that encryption
I think so too very very fast Hitler was
like the only reason that he was who he
was for the most part is because of the
technology that he had like telephone uh
I don't know what their phone situations
were like yeah telephone they had video
they had film you know the manipulation
of film and radio got an entire country
of people rallied around him so now
we're just that on the next magnitude of
global yo communication
guys Enigma was like considered
unbreakable it was a it was originally
cracked in like the late 30s by a Polish
dude and then Alan Turing famously
worked on this machine to to crack it I
I just Google searched on quora it says
how long would it take today's computers
to crack the Enigma machine and the sky
Rupert Baines responds
gchq the UK version of NSA did it with a
Raspberry Pi and Legos in 15 seconds
[Laughter]
dude imagine taking one of those things
back to World War II
crazy yeah and for that headline the
other part of it is so Luke says the the
government could make this chess move so
the media matter says don't look at the
move don't look at the move doesn't that
make you even think more like you're
gonna make that move why would you why
would you not acknowledge that that move
could be made the downsides to pushing
everybody to electric and they called me
an Infowars employee I was never an
Infowars employee you got that wrong
again well they just post fake news I
mean get your facts straight like if
you're gonna call me an employee of a
former company okay let's fact check
that I actually work for that company I
I did it I got a mess I really like
Media Matters because all they really do
is create like Eclipse clips of the show
it's like
it's like aside from putting the word
absurd in the title I really don't mind
that they're clipping the show and
sharing it with everybody and then they
just run um the uh the advertising
what's the text they were on the uh it's
just a transcript yeah I noticed that
articles like at the bottom it's like
in this article Tim Poole and then I'm
like oh it says they for some reason
they use this picture of me from like 12
years ago what's up with that I'm glad
they brought up this it's hard to find
pictures of you I think Tim I don't
think I'm on the show every single night
well other than screenshots of the show
oh that's the black and the red
background to make it kind of look like
fascists you know what I love uh this
one right here it says extremist bigots
and conspiracy theorists YouTuber
temples 2022 guests in review and it's
like they they try really hard to smear
people like the things they were saying
about Adrienne Curry it's just like are
you what are you are you nuts like
they're just desperately trying to make
everybody extreme right and I'm pretty
sure they did not put Sheamus on the
list and Sheamus was like I was a
co-host of that show for seven months it
was the most extreme the most bigoted
she's like I'm a conservative Catholic I
did make the like one of the problems I
feel like Media Matters is having in a
lot of companies are is that they're
looking for drama where there doesn't
have to be DNA sometimes he's just
talking about stuff yeah I think part of
it is to make sure that what they what
they're really afraid of just like when
Tim did his event this weekend they're
afraid of you going out and meeting
people and talking to people of all
different political spectrums so media
matter does that and it's less likely
that you're going to get a leftist on
your show right they don't want to be
called of right wing or you're convert
you're talking with all these radical
people so it keeps you in the Echo
chamber I think they're really that's
why I like the Tim the idea you guys are
doing with the coffee shops like let's
get together and talk it can be
apolitical I'm wearing a yaira shirt
from Eric July he has his comic book he
made this character up and that's just
like you guys do your music it's it's um
apolitical they don't they don't want
um Jake euger on this show they wouldn't
want that I know it would be contentious
but they don't want people of different
politics coming on I don't think with
the krasensteins on yeah it was kind of
like it was kind of boring yeah it was
just like we know each other's opinions
and we disagree and it's like okay you
know because a lot of people were like
Tim push back harder and I'm like the
dudes are allowed to have opinions we
disagree with I can't I I can't be like
I think your opinion is wrong it's like
well I think your facts are wrong like
here's what I think you're and they're
like well we like these things and I'm
like well you're allowed to like them
yeah but those discussions are important
though so I they don't want that
happening but why do you think that is
why they don't want that happen yeah
there's no speculation at this point
well I mean I'm playing chess too I
think they want everybody funneled
online the pandemic was a great
opportunity because you can control
people with algorithms and it's very
hard online to break out of your
algorithm so they don't want people
convert if you talk with somebody else
then you can say Hey Oh I got this
problem too my kids are having this
problem at school and then all of a
sudden how do you do stochastic
terrorism if I know you and I we have a
connection and you're my neighbor or
we've had a couple of discussions and
somebody says oh he's saying all this
radical stuff you can't really make make
that stick I know him I'm not worried
about your thing so the the bit I think
the solution to all of this is
connecting with people I mean right Tim
I mean that's what you're doing with
your culture stuff thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time